When someone tells me that um toyotaro
has not surpassed the character Yama I
just laugh in their face bro okay so I
mean no disrespect to Toyota Tower here
I'm sure he would even freely admit that
he's nowhere near the level of the OG
but this level of Toriyama slander I
honestly just can't deal with right now
Dragon Ball built a legacy on
exaggerated camera angles ridiculous
unique creative posing and these
Immaculate page spreads and while
toratara has done some incredible work
and gotten a lot better over the years
he himself will even freely admit that
he's got a lot of room to grow his oddly
clunky illustration abilities when it
comes to certain poses like take this
one for example this shoulder on Frost
just looks all kinds of wrong there's an
instance where he tries to draw zamas
and Toriyama just draws it for him in
the actual manga and it looks so much
better I mean look at this image here on
the left is toyotaro on the right is
Toriyama and you can see that difference
night and day it's not even a comparison